- They said I
should be denounced
and I should never be hired
again so that was pretty tricky.
So I then hired a lawyer
straightaway and I said,
"You've gotta withdraw
that statement
"and all that sort of
stuff and pay my costs"
which they did, that was good.
But still, the thing
about these great attacks
that people launch on you
is once they've launched the
attack on you, it sticks,
as long as they throw enough
shit, some of it will stick,
so you'll sort of walk
around, but weirdly,
when I walk around the streets
people come up to me and go,
"Thank God for you."
But when I walk around on
Twitter people come up to me
and go, "I hope you and
your family die soon."
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Standard game.
(warm instrumental music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a British actor and activist.
He's also the founder
of the Reclaim Party
and hopefully the
next mayor of London.
Laurence Fox, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Hi, Dave, how you doing?
- I'm doing just fine, sir.
I'm glad to talk to
you across the pond.
For my American audience
that maybe doesn't know
who you are, can you give me
the quick recap of Laurence Fox
before we talk about
all the reasons
that you got
yourself into trouble
and how you got into
politics and all that.
- Well, I was an actor,
and actually some
of your American
friends will know me
because I got off
the plane at JFK once
and a guy was helping
me with my bag and said,
"I love you in the
'Inspector Lewis' show."
So that was quite, so I
was an actor for many years
and then yeah, like you
say, I got into trouble.
I got canceled.
- All right, so let's talk
about your cancellation.
You were on a British show
called "Question Time."
It's about a year ago now,
and we're gonna play a
clip in just a second,
but can you just sort of set
up what "Question Time" is
and how you even got
involved in it as an actor?
And a little bit of the
behind the scenes portion.
- Sure, yeah, so "Question
Time" is a sort of topical
panel show, political
panel show in the UK.
It's been around
for donkey's years,
and it's usually quite
very left-leaning,
and sort of very establishment.
But by some accident
they invited a slightly
more centrist panel on,
and I was promoting because
I'm a musician as well, so
I was promoting an album,
and someone said to me,
"Do you want to go
on 'Question Time?'"
And I'm like, "Yeah, sure,"
'cause it's a sort of
family tradition in the UK,
people just shout at the
TV and go, "It's rubbish!
No, you're wrong!"
And I thought I'd get
to do that on live TV.
And then yeah, a woman
started asking question of me,
asking what my opinion
was about something,
and I said what my opinion
was and she disagreed
and said I wasn't allowed an
opinion because I was White.
So I was like, "Oh,
hang on, that's racist."
So I said, "Don't be racist."
And then, (mimics
explosion pounding) yeah.
- Boom, so we're
just gonna throw
to that one 30-second
clip right now.
- Let's be really clear
about what this is,
let's call it by its
name, it's racism.
- We're in the most tolerant,
lovely country in Europe.
- [Audience Member] Says
a White privileged man.
- It's not racist.
It's starting to get boring now.
- What worries me
about your comment is,
you are a White privileged
male who has never experienced-
- Oh, God.
(audience booing)
- I'm gonna, can I just, I-
- I can't help what I am.
I was born like this, it's
an immutable characteristic.
- So therefore you cannot-
- So to call me a White
privileged male is to be racist.
You're being racist.
(audience applauding)
- You cannot dismiss.
- Okay.
- So, boy, you claimed that
you're entitled to opinion
even though you're White,
how radical of you.
- It's awful, isn't it?
I mean, we should
have learned by now
that you're not
allowed an opinion,
immutable characteristics
ahead of everything else.
But it was weird,
I didn't know it was
such an enormous landmine
in the UK so it was crazy.
The next day I got
a bit of support
and then it just went mad,
left Twitter went for me.
- Yeah, so can you talk
about that experience
'cause obviously
we're in the midst
of this just insane
cancel culture thing
and on any given day we're
taking out Pepé Le Pew
or Mr. Potato Head
or Aunt Jemima
or sometimes real people, too.
But can you just talk
about what it feels like
to be the target of that?
Because that's when
you came on my radar,
it was basically like, oh,
here's a guy telling the truth
and then just to watch
the mob descend on you.
- I was okay until the
actors' union, Equity,
the actors union, you
know how non-left-wing
show business is.
- Oh, yes, they're
very fair, very minor.
- So they said that
I should be denounced
and I should never be hired
again so that was pretty tricky.
So I then hired a lawyer
straight away and I said,
"You've got to
withdraw that statement
'and all that sort of
stuff and pay my costs"
which they did, that was good.
But still, the thing
about these great attacks
that people launch on you
is once they've launched the
attack on you, it sticks.
As long as they throw enough
shit some of it will stick,
so you'll sort of walk
around, but weirdly,
when I walk around the streets
people come up to me and go,
"Thank God for you," but
when I walk around on Twitter
people come up to me and go,
"I hope you and your
family die soon."
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Standard game.
- Right.
So what would you say to
the people who would say,
"Oh, but this is just
some online thing then,
"it's just the Twitter mob
and you should get over
"just people being
mean on Twitter,
"you don't have
to be on Twitter?"
- Well, Twitter is pointless
and a sewer of humanity,
which is fine, but also it does
affect people in real life,
like the mayor of London,
the sitting mayor of London
at the moment, Sadiq
Khan, he's like...he takes
sort of virtue signaling
identitarianism
to a whole new
level of division.
He called me in the newspaper
when they were asked
for a comment about me,
he called me a far-right,
extreme far-right guy.
And I'm like, "Okay,
that's pretty uncool
"'cause I've got two kids."
I can walk around to the shop.
If someone who's only over read
that little bit of newspaper
the capital city newspaper
and someone decides
they want to put a brick
or a knife into me,
then this whole sort of
freedom of speech thing,
'cause I actually defend
his right to call me
an extreme far-right
whatever he wants to call me.
He's a bit of a wanker, to
be fair, so I don't care.
- We'll get to him
in just a moment.
- You know when they say that
they go freedom of speech
and freedom of consequences
of the freedom of speech,
I'm like, if my kids get
attacked or if I get attacked,
who's the consequences
on, are they on you?
And also, can you
say one simple thing
that I've ever said which
is even vaguely right-wing.
- Right, okay, so basically
the usual story unfolds,
you say a very moderate thing
in line with British values,
defending free speech, which
is really what you were doing
on the panel the whole time,
next thing you know, the
mayor's calling you far right,
there's a gajillion hit pieces,
you've got the union going
after you, the Twitter mob,
like all of that stuff and
then you sort of, I think,
once you got over it
you kind of embraced it
because your life in
the last year, I mean,
you started a political party,
you're running for mayor,
you kinda ran right
into the fire.
- You can't do anything
else, there's no option.
I'm good friends with
Winston Marshall as well
and I've been watching
from (indistinct)
watching while he's
trying to put out
that...he's trying to
bow to the woke mob.
He's actually trying to do
the right thing, really,
but I'm just sat there
going, "Don't do it buddy."
- Yeah.
- Don't do it-
- To be clear,
he's the guitarist,
guitarist, right,
for Mumford & Sons?
- Banjo player
for Mumford, yeah.
- Banjo player for
Mumford & Sons.
He's the one who dared
to recommended Andy Ngo's
scary book about Antifa.
- I'm mates with both of them,
and I'm on the phone
to both of them,
and Andy's in the
UK at the moment
'cause I want Andy to come
and work for me for the party,
I really would like that, so
I'm mates with both of them.
It's hilarious, and
they love each other
and then this sort of public
crapstorm going on around,
well, different approaches
to deal with a woke mob,
who you can never say sorry to.
- Yeah.
- They love it.
- Has he heard any of
your feelings about this?
Like, that you just
can't apologize,
that this is gonna
get you nowhere,
I mean he's not even in
the band anymore right?
At least temporarily.
- I was speaking, we were
laughing about it on the phone.
You know, it's really difficult.
It's like how do you, he's
a truly compassionate,
gentle guy, he doesn't want
major conflicts in life.
I don't mind being
punched in the face
for stuff I believe
in, but I think
he's just trying to
do the right thing.
And actually I think
people who do give in,
they need more love
because it's just people
hanging around the
guillotine, right?
Going, more, more beheadings
that's what they like.
It gives me the shivers.
I like standing up to
them, they need it.
- Yeah, well, they do need it.
So all right, so assuming
that you're not far-right,
I'm willing to go on
this adventure with you.
- Okay.
- Because in your Twitter bio
you describe yourself
as a fierce liberal.
What does liberal mean
to you at this point?
Because I know there's
a slightly different
British version.
You know my feelings on
classical liberalism.
Do you think the word
liberal can be saved?
Does it even make sense
in the sort of modern
context anymore?
- I think, yeah, you do have
a slight difficulty with it
in America, don't you?
An American friend
bought me a mug
saying liberal tears still
warm, but that's leftists
to us here.
- Right.
- My liberalism
would not probably,
with the Overton window
where it is in society
would probably be seen
as quite right-wing.
I want people to get on
with their own lives,
make their own decisions
about what they do
and keep as much of
their money as possible
and not pay it to
an enormous state.
So it's just about being free
to make your own
decisions in life.
That's where my
liberalism comes from.
And yeah, I think we can save it
because ultimately it's
going to be, weirdly,
it's gonna be the
left-of-center liberals
that save the situation
because until they
start standing up
there's no point in people
like me going, guys,
there's a big problem here
with freedom of speech.
We're gonna have a big
fight if we're not careful.
We need people from the left
to come in and go,
this isn't cool.
And it's starting
to happen, isn't it?
They're eating
their own as well.
- Yeah, what signs
are you seeing?
Like I've just
sort of come around
to that the sane liberals,
they don't have to change
their beliefs at all.
I mean, I wrote a whole
book defending liberalism,
but they have to ally with
the moderates on the right,
which I think is most of
America at this point.
Just freedom-loving
people and we can debate
about tax rates and
all that kind of stuff.
Do you see some signs
that the decent liberals
are waking up and fighting
some of the woke stuff?
'Cause there's not much
here, there's just not much.
- It's a very difficult
subject for politicians,
certainly, to get involved with.
We've got a Conservative
party here which is, I mean,
they're not even
vaguely conservative.
They're almost a socialist
party on their own.
And then the opposition party
is even more left
wing than that.
So we're in difficult,
difficult times actually
because it's an attack on
everything, it's not attack on
It's an attack on
values, love of family,
love of country, it's an
attack on all the things
that were okay to love.
And we had this horrible
murder a few days ago in London
of this girl and then there
was a vigil held for her
and the police got
too involved really
'cause we've basically turned
into a police state here.
And within minutes it turned
into a leftist demonstration.
So we're now getting
what you have in Portland
starting the rumblings
of in London.
Screaming, neurotic
lunatics going on.
Like one minute they'll go,
"whose streets, our streets."
And then they'll be on to,
"Fuck the police,
kill the police."
They don't know what
they're screaming about,
but they're angry.
- Yeah, who are they
organized in any way?
I mean, this is the
big debate in America.
Is Antifa just an idea?
Like is Andy tracking
this, Andy Ngo?
Is that why he's
there right now?
- Yeah, Andy was
there the other day.
Yeah, he's tracking it.
I don't think they're
that organized.
I think social media
is helpful, isn't it,
for crazy people with crazy
views to get together, so-
- But what are they even, I
mean, from a British perspective
what are they protesting?
Or they just don't know?
- I went to the
protest so I was like,
I need to know what these
guys are upset about,
and I couldn't work it out.
They were just screaming.
It was one thing to the next.
It was meant to be about
this dreadful crime,
this murder of this woman,
but it became about
something else.
It was like, let's
kill the police,
and it was ACAB, All
Cops are Bastards.
And it's like, well, are they?
You know, I don't understand.
No one knew what was going on.
They were just marching
up and down the street
and then they went and lay down
in Trafalgar Square for a while.
I think basically either
they weren't paying attention
in school or they're
not interested in
history or anything.
- Yeah, how do you think
the lockdowns fit into this
because you guys are still
in pretty severe
lockdowns right now?
- We are in severe lockdown.
No one's paying any
attention to it, though.
It's so British, it's
like, mm-hmm, yes.
Whenever they poll the
British people they're like,
"Are you all in lockdown,
are you supportive of it?"
And the Brits are like, "Yes,
absolutely, we're supportive."
And then I walk out my door
down the street and I look at
on the window it says, stay
at home, protect the NHS,
save lives, and then
you look downstairs
and people are having
a drinks party.
So it's do as I
say not do as I do.
- Yeah, so all right, you're
a radical right-wing guy
trying to defend liberalism.
- Extreme right wing, Dave.
- Extreme right winger
trying to defend liberalism.
So you walk in through the fire.
You decide, okay, I'm
not gonna be canceled.
I'm gonna see what happens.
And then how did you
make the shift to say,
well, I'm actually gonna
freaking start a political party
and run for office?
It's one thing to survive
it, but then to really say,
I'm going in and I'm
going to do something.
- Well, it's just such a gap.
So after this we
did, I had a feeling
that there was a large
constituency of people
that just weren't being
allowed to express themselves.
So there's this huge
freedom of speech hole.
So I thought, that needs mending
because we have to have a
proper debate about everything
including lockdowns
actually, weirdly
'cause they haven't
been talked about.
They've just been, you
must accept that lockdowns
are a good thing and
there's no debate allowed.
So yeah, I got approached
by a very rich businessman
who said, "what do you wanna do
"'cause you will not lie down.
"You're like, you keep standing
up like some stupid boxer
"who doesn't know when
the battle is finished."
And I said, "Well, I should
do something in media."
And I actually mentioned
you because you're actually
responsible for some of
this, as I told you before.
- And again, I
apologize, you know.
- (laughs) And he said,
"No, no, you need
a political party."
He said, "They'll only
ever listen to you
if you have a political party."
So weirdly we started
at the political party
and suddenly the culture
became important again
to our Conservative government
because they're
trying to hold me off
on what would essentially be
on the liberal side of things
but is now the sort
of extreme far-right
as our lovely mayor calls me.
- Yeah, so this morning
I went to the Reclaim website
and you basically write
and open letter describing
why you started the party
and what the beliefs are.
And I thought it was
quite perfect, actually.
Can you describe some of
the principles, again,
these crazy right-wing
liberal principles
that you're defending?
- Well, I think
it's really simple.
I'm defending an idea so it's
not really about me anyway.
So you should be able to
protect yourself from attack.
If you believe in
freedom of speech,
you believe in everybody's
freedom to speak, right.
So that's what I stand for.
I stand for the biggest
and broadest debate
to be had possible and then
what I've done practically
is I've commissioned,
which is actually
gonna be quite big
news in England soon
which is gonna shock them,
I've commissioned a full
and huge legal review of all
of the legal impingements
on freedom of speech
'cause you know,
you've got your Equality
Act going through,
and what's it called, H.R. 1?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Or whatever is going
through in America.
Now, we had this shit.
They did this in
like 2010 in the UK.
We have our own Equality Act
where people had
protected characteristics
and they're not
equal under the law.
So all of this stuff is
really dangerous legislation.
And I've commissioned
a full review.
And there's some
very eminent, top
top top people who have put
together a suggestion
for the British people
and for the parliament about
how we can lose
division in society.
But it's weird when you
try and lose division,
you tend to attract
divisive people.
- Yeah, it seems to be
are you worried that in essence,
you'll sort of see
like, just that,
like practical level,
that you'll sort
of split the conservatives,
because some conservatives
will go with you,
the rest will stay
with the conservatives.
And then ultimately,
you just help labor
and the Labour Party as
you sort of said before,
kind of gone off the rails.
- I think the conservative
candidate in London
is not he's such a
sweet guy as well,
which I find so difficult,
'cause he's a really
lovely guy, but he's not.
For some reason, he's not
creating the right waves.
So no, I think what I want
and what would be best
would be for me, and Sadiq
our mayor who likes to
race bait on a daily basis
to debate and talk
about our capital city.
And, what's his vision for it?
And 'cause, he's
got this is called
the commission for diversity
in the public realm.
He's got and it sounds lovely.
- It always sounds lovely.
It always sounds lovely
- But it's just like, let's
tear down all our statues.
And he's already had
to kick one member off,
he's in about a surprisingly,
for the left extreme
left an avowed anti Semite,
who would have thought it
- Shocking in the Labour
Party I can't believe it.
- Are you?
It's weird, isn't it right?
The people that call you racist,
they are the exact thing
they accuse you of.
So he's, it blows my mind train?
- Well, so in essence, you
wanted debate Sadiq Khan?
And yeah, and do you sense
that that could happen?
Or is it a pipe dream?
I mean, will he do it?
- Who knows, man,
we've got a pretty
cool campaign.
On the Thursday, we're
gonna start dropping there.
some of the more importantly,
controversial but needing to
be said statements to London.
I mean, like, at
the end of the day,
London is like the
cathedral have woken,
like any Metropolitan center.
So, for me, the most
important thing is just
to raise the voice for the
people who don't get to speak.
That's it the only
reason I do it.
- So Alright, so you guys
are seeing some violence
in London with sort of
sort of newish violence.
There's the lockdowns,
we were mentioning right before
we started recording that,
we have a couple of friends
in common Douglas Murray
and Peter Lloyd and
a few other people.
Peter basically has fled London
and everyone that I talked
to that's in London
is really not happy
about what's going on there.
what besides the
free speech stuff has
Sadiq Khan done wrong?
- What he's what
is he done right?
Really, it's the way you have
to start all right here.
It is terrible.
We've got a surging knife
crime problem in London.
And then that's made
almost unsolvable because
of the way that he Stokes
racial tensions between people.
So he calls you a
racist if you try
and deal with knife crime,
and he would call you a racist.
He's, obviously trying
to tear down all
of our shared history.
And what did he
say the other day?
He said something like,
there's just no reason
why there should be 65%
of these people should
be white men working in
this particular field,
and you're like,
hang on a minute,
dude just slow down.
This country's 83 or
85% white, of course,
it's gonna be more white people.
it's this very specific
demonization of white people.
Unfortunately, he has a huge
constituency of white people
who also hate
themselves as well,
the sort of white
urban liberals.
And it's like,
it's really sad because
most of the working class
in the United Kingdom would
usually vote labour they would.
But labour don't
represent labor.
They don't represent laborers.
And they don't represent
actually the important things,
which are class issues
in this country.
Britain is constantly
in frequent,
I think, after New Zealand,
and I can't remember
where else we
are the most tolerant
country on Earth,
in terms of like tolerance
of intermarriage and all this
sort of stuff.
So I don't know why.
At the center of the ultra woke,
our mayor is trying
to turn around and go,
you know what,
guys, you're racist.
It's like, come
on, man it's 2021.
We've got to get a new story.
- Yeah but it's basically
it's all they got.
Right I mean that's, in essence,
what you were saying
in that clip earlier.
Like, it's all they got without
that what policy could
he possibly be pushing?
That makes any sense?
I know, he doesn't
have any policies.
So he's, and also
the worst part of it
is he's kind of a
government stooge, as well.
So the government of bribing
him to make him look bad.
And it's just so political,
and I can't bear it.
So when I get into
involved in this stuff,
I just go, listen,
I don't have any lobbyists
or vested interest.
I'm not, supported or
funded by these people.
So this is what I would do
to solve x, y, and Z problem.
So we'll just have to see.
- Does it feel to you guys,
like a lot of this
stuff has been imported
from the US that are bad ideas,
or the bad ideas that have
taken root here suddenly
are exploited all
over the place?
- Yeah, I mean, when you go
to what the BBC described
as a largely peaceful protest
of the Black Lives
Matter last summer,
there were people
walking around,
going Hands up, don't shoot.
And I'm like, our police
forces aren't armed.
- They literally
don't have guns.
- We've imported this
straight from America,
which is a great
honor to America,
'cause we love American
trends and all that stuff.
But this is one American trend
that we should stay behind.
But at least you get
to keep Megan right.
- Well, apparently she's
gonna run for president now.
That's the new
meme we're hearing
- And she'd win.
She'd win, wouldn't she?
- Where are we gonna go?
- Fiji,
- Fiji that's the spot.
- Yeah that's yeah,
- That's the spot.
so America's importing this
or exporting this stuff?
You guys are are
importing this stuff.
What's it gonna take?
Is it okay, we can
take back London
by getting the same Mayor
like what's the real move
to really reverse this thing?
Well, it's an interesting
thing that's developed now.
So there's a
constituency in the,
in the north of Britain
called the Red Wall,
which was always held
by the Labour Party,
and it totally fell down
the friction and went
to the conservatives.
They lent their votes
to conservatives,
some constituencies hadn't voted
conservative for 100 years.
And today, one of
the labor weirdly,
why would it be the labor guy
who's being done for
sexual harassment
had to resign immediately.
- It's weird that that's
always them too, isn't it?
It's so bizarre?
- What's going on here.
It's almost like they're the
exact thing they accuse us of.
So that he's had to
stand down today.
So there's now going
to be a by election.
And it'll be very,
very interesting to see
what happens up there.
But ultimately, I think, if
you can open up the dialog,
and you can say, listen,
there's 70 million
people in this country.
We're not all racists.
We're not.
And I will stand up and
say we're not then you.
It's, these guys have been
doing this for decades.
Haven't they marching
through our universities,
not even my kids, right?
My youngest son said
to me, I'm sorry,
if this is racist dad.
But mom is a better
cook than you.
And am like, what, say what now?
So they're filling
it in their heads,
like constantly
when Trump got ill?
We even really get out.
Did he really get
COVID but when,
- Whatever two days
he disappeared,
- They announced it in
the school assembly.
And then everyone
started cheering.
And it's like my little son
was I didn't want to cheer.
I don't want to cheer when
someone's not very well.
So they're hammering it in
the education establishment
is really bad I think
what you have to do
is they might see the
institution slowly,
will march straight back in.
- So do you think
the institutions
are worth saving?
Or would you say that they
should be just rebuilt
or just totally
new institutions?
- I think they have to
be reclaimed that I think
that's why I call it reclaim,
- Yeah,
- They have to be reclaimed.
It's 95% of academics are pretty
hard left in university and
that's not cool you
can't have a good debate
when 95% of people
agree with each other.
they've bought into even
mild acting school as bought
totally bought into critical
race theory and anti racism
and stuff like that.
But I thought it was excellent
what Prince William said
when he said this
family is not racist.
And that was a deliberate
little spike at his brother
and his sort of weird anti
racist narcissist crap
from his puppet master wife.
- What's going on with
that whole situation
that I covered it for like
two seconds on the show.
I didn't watch the
full Oprah interview.
It's not that interesting, to me
Honestly, from an
American perspective,
we just have bigger
problems at the moment.
but is Megan gonna, like,
take down the whole monarchy?
That's kind of
what it feels like,
like that she's
gonna import all of
these horrible ideas,
and just that this is
a threat to everything.
- I don't think
she will succeed,
because I think there's a
huge amount of goodwill there.
Like, if you look at the
photos of that wedding,
particularly where
there's so much goodwill.
I mean, we're gonna
we have princes
and princesses in
this country, right?
You're not gonna hate your
princess and Princess.
So there was so much goodwill,
but what we cannot abide
is what she's done,
which is trying to make her
she's a being political, which,
you shouldn't be
doing as a royal.
I think she's just
taking control
of a very compassionate guy.
And she's realized she's
not gonna be the center
of attention.
So she's gone, right?
What I didn't wanna be in
the royal family anymore.
And then, in true
kind of vengeful,
narcissist style, she's gone.
I'm gonna take it down.
So she's accused all of them
of being racist by not being
particular about what it is.
And it's a very, and I know
how powerful that insult is,
'cause I get called
racist all the time.
And it really affects you,
especially if you've
got a heart if you like,
I was not expecting
to be called that.
And so I think what will happen
is the royal family will
just find it very cool,
very calm way of going.
Bye now, stay over there.
- How does the media
play into all of this?
Because you guys are well
known for your tabloid media.
I've had the Guardian
call me racist,
and far right, and
all of that stuff.
So even though we've
obviously export it,
a lot of the bad ideas, one
of the things that I think
that you guys have
exploited is some of like,
the tabloid journalism
kind of stuff.
Like it's now everywhere here.
It's like, basically,
there's no difference
between the National Enquirer
and the New York
Times at this point.
- Yeah, former newspaper.
And it's very sad.
It's been particularly
sad over lockdown,
because the
government briefed the
and they're now finding
redacted statements
within the scientific
advisory group
that have been saying,
we need to get the people
frightened and stuff like this.
So the government
has briefed the media
and the media have loved it,
they've then set the whole
population on fire and fear.
And now everyone is terrified,
and they can't move.
So I think the media but
it's free speech, right?
Unlike, say what you want.
But just can we just
have more of the
whole picture instead of just
a very focused picture on
on what we want to attack
and what is,
relevant to your kind
of selling newspapers narrative?
It's been bad but even
Piers Morgan writing
by the I mean.
- Yeah well, it has
Piers doing right now,
after he walked off the set?
- He was I was quite
friendly with Piers.
And then we fell out over COVID.
So I've been saying
to that he's now
that he's realized, 'cause
he jumps on bandwagon.
So to her in America,
when Shapiro,
just ate him for breakfast
over the assault rifle stuff.
So he's doing the same thing.
He's just reinventing himself,
we got a new news channel,
opening up in the
UK called GB news,
which is run by Andrew Neil,
who's probably one of
the best journalists
we have in the country.
And hopefully, that'll bring
a bit more balance into it,
but they're already trying
to get back canceled as well.
- Yeah do you guys
have like, like,
who are the British voices
that we should know that
that we don't know?
Like who else putting you
on on the map right now?
- Definitely, Andrew Nail,
the newspapers that
have not given in
to the work agenda,
but some of them have.
Most of them have.
But the Telegraph Newspaper
hasn't really given
in the times that this
horrible evisceration
of Jordan Peterson,
the other day,
and I was just like,
Fuck yeah, fuck you.
I was saying that was
meant to be a sort
of centrist moderate paper.
And they're just like,
stab, stab, stab.
So the Telegraph, the Express,
which if you'd said the
Express 10 years ago,
or 15 years ago in the UK,
they would have gone Nazi.
But now it's like a
bastion of centrism.
It's weird.
- What about 'cause I know
what people will say okay.
You guys are saying
you're downplaying racism
and by Baidu,
what about the real people
that actually are racist?
The real far right
people, whatever,
whatever influence those
groups have, first off,
do they have any real influence
at this point, please,
in American context,
there are no legit
political racist groups.
There just aren't.
That isn't to say there
aren't racist people
there are of course,
but they have been marginalized.
- Are you trying to say
that the left create
imaginary bogeyman,
- I'm starting to think we're
thinking in a similar way?
- Yeah, see the far
right in England,
and it does exist, but I mean,
there's probably not
very many of them.
it's not and they don't
really have any power.
No one listens to them.
No, no bought at having the
best time ever because thing
is everyone's a racist.
They're just hiding
in plain sight.
No, I think the thing is,
we in this sort of
new woke religion
that we've found ourselves in,
and we're looking for heaven.
Heaven is a world of no racism,
which everyone would
like to welcome
a racism but unfortunately,
human beings are fallen
within the population.
- You'll have to kill
an awful lot of human.
- Yeah, you're gonna find
that there are gonna be
some actual racist,
and what you want to do
is educate their children.
That's all you wanna do.
And you've got a
nasty racist, dude,
what are you gonna try
and convince him off,
but his kid you can educate?
And hopefully, this
child can turn out not
to be racist, but we've done I'm
so I mean, I'm raising the
patriotic about this country.
I think we're amazing.
And I think America has kind
of fallen for the
next four years,
we'll see what happens.
China's powerful actually,
you've got really,
I love the fact
that you get your own.
Soldiers get no get
to choose the color
of their own combat
gear now that sounds
- Yes, yes china is their
chaps at the moment.
- China's just
going, this is great.
And we've got so I think
England needs we need
to look at England to go
what do you guys think?
And I think you need to go well,
we believe that we must
stand freely together.
And we and we see all men
and women equal under the law.
I mean, what's so
complicated about that crap,
that's a 75% issue
in our country.
- It's almost like the things
that you've been
doing for a long time,
something like that.
- See if that 1000 years
to see if that sort
of 900 years since the Magna
Carta was worth carrying
on pursuing Oh,
hang on a minute.
No, let's just tear
the whole thing down
and start again.
What do you want to
start with leftists?
Nothing just fire and chaos.
- And quotas is, don't
fire chaos and quotas.
Don't forget the quotas.
- Exactly, you must
remember the quotas
- Where does Brexit
fit into all of this?
And do you feel freer
now than you did say?
Well, I guess not
because a lockdowns,
but putting lockdowns aside,
would you feel a
little freer now?
- I think Brexit is amazing.
I didn't vote for
Brexit I voted to remain
'cause I just like why change
it, it's sort of my vibe.
But now that I've
seen how duplicitous
and evil the European Union
have been certainly
over the vaccine stuff
and over Northern Ireland,
Brexitiears are now probably
just below deplore just
above deplorable status.
So you wouldn't spit
at them in the street,
but you would try and have
them canceled from work?
Yeah, Brexit was a very
big central cultural
issue for our country.
So there's still people
who maraud around online.
Actually, most of the
bullies have a European flag
in their Twitter
bio, and it says FBPE
Follow Back Pro Europe.
And I think Brexit has
divided the country,
but I imagine that
52% that voted Brexit
are probably now what
if you if you did
that vote again,
I think you'd find it
probably be more 60, 40.
- So you think people
realize that being in charge
of their own lives is
better than outsourcing it
to Brussels crazy.
- Outsourcing it to
an unelected body.
Exactly yeah I think
it's been really good.
I'm really I think
it's exciting.
But the problem
is Boris Johnson's
had this chance to go, right.
We've done Brexit, what
are we gonna look like?
what are we gonna
be as a country?
And instead he's gone
like, okay, darling,
more with pumps, more wins.
- What's the deal with Boris?
I think a lot of people
thought he was gonna be
much more bullish and
bold than he's been.
And it sounds like that just
kind of hasn't happened.
- Mistress nock nock.
- Yeah,
- He's girl, yeah,
yeah his girl.
His girlfriend his time.
She's an entirely
new level of work.
And he's got a load
of kids apparently,
who are also woke because
Boris was never good at knowing
how many children
he had exactly.
So he does a good
line in it right?
But here's the thing
is he's a trained classicist.
So if you've got a national
health service here going,
we're gonna rename
breastfeeding, chest feeding.
You're like, come on, dude.
You're a classical linguist.
You should care about language,
but he's just like zip
So he's all about dolphins
and wind turbines,
which is great for when it's.
- I can't tell are you
hopeful or pessimistic?
Generally speaking.
- I'm sort of, I'm optimistic,
but I find this whole
thing so amusing.
It's so difficult
not to find it mad.
Do what I mean, you're
sitting there going?
are we sitting through a very
important period of history?
We are I never
thought I'd watch it.
My dad is 81.
And he said to me the other day,
I was like, how do you feel?
He went, undeclared
I'll be dead soon.
I'm so glad I won't be around
when the fire starts.
I'm like, oh dad.
- But he does know you're trying
to put out the fire.
- Yeah, and he's cool.
My dad, like, he's a
good inspiration for me.
So we walk a lot,
and we talk and he's
smart about these things.
So we can't put the fire out.
I think ultimately
what will happen
is people will just go stop
and I think my mates
you've got kids
who are like, 15,16, they're
not working they hate.
- That that seems
to be the new thing
that that Zoomers,
like that generation,
the upper teens right now
that they're gonna reject
this stuff with a boldness
that somehow well,
certainly the baby
boomers failed on.
And, we're roughly the same age
that our Gen Z
people failed on but
that they won't hopefully.
- Yeah, I think they
are the hope, otherwise,
it's gonna be chaos, isn't it?
It's gonna be like the
it's almost like the
French Revolution.
But the wind up the thing that
I find terrifying about it,
is you're constantly
goading, because obviously,
we get America about
two months later.
So you've now gone from white
privilege to white supremacy.
And we're now getting the
white supremacy thing,
and you're saying
this to like the one
of the poorest constituencies
in the country.
So white working class boys
in England chances and going
to university are
very, very low.
So you're turning
around to a bunch
of poor white kids and saying,
check your privilege.
And then you've also
got an a whole load
of communities from Asia all
the way across from India
to China who don't get included
in Black Lives Matter.
So it's like it's so divisive,
and it's so unpleasant.
So I think it should be
stood up against I mean,
I'm it's just unfair that I'm
kind of blond and blue eyed
because it would be just exactly
the wrong skin color makeup
to make the opposing.
- What is exactly the right one,
'cause it's just enough of this.
And that's why I wanted
to have you on the show.
Because you aren't
afraid of this thing.
Like you had your moment
and you didn't run
a lot of people,
they put that apology out
there and you never hear
from them again, and
you didn't do it.
What else should we tell
people about the Reclaim Party
and how they can help you
and get word out there
and all that good stuff?
- Well, you can go we're
not accepting donations
at the moment because
I want people to see
that I am working rather
than getting freebies.
So you can just spread the word
all I've been saying to when
someone says how can
I help you, as I say,
find someone you
disagree with and go
and have a
conversation with them.
That's the best thing you can do
to help the Reclaim Party
and actually your own culture
and your society.
Stay the right way up.
- Laurence Fox, you
are a fierce liberal
in the best sense of liberal,
for whatever sense
that word still has.
You are the best type.
So thanks for doing this.
We're gonna link obviously
to the party down below.
And good luck.
And can I host the debate
between you and Sadiq.
You think he'd come on the show?
What do you think?
What do you think ?
- You should invite
him on the show
'cause I think that he's
so keen on being right on?
And you're super, would he know?
I'd be really
interested in seeing
he doesn't really do interviews,
like even the other day
when someone was trying to
ask him 'cause he's closed
off all the neighborhoods
in London as well right?
So he's gone if it's not
an essential journey.
You won't make it
because I will just close
off all the neighborhoods
so these people were trying
to talk to him about it go
but why do you get to choose it
if its an essential journey?
And he just was he
has like six he's like
a mafia boss got six
security guards fleet
of Range Rovers, all
on the taxpayer dollar.
He's quite a character, man.
I would like to.
- Yeah, you got your
work cut out for you.
Well, I do hope it happens.
We're gonna link to Reclaim
Party down below Lawrence.
Good luck, man.
- Piece brother.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international
issues instead
of non stop yelling,
check out our international
playlist and if you wanna watch
full interviews on
a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.